you know the idea that we're just going
to
you know sort of be able to get the
definitive answer from science
and it's going to tell us exactly what
to do unfortunately
you know that it's interesting because
let me point out
that if that was possible if science
could always tell us what to do
then in a sense our you know that would
be a big downer for our lives
if science could always tell us what the
answer is going to be it's like
well you know it's kind of fun to live
one's life and just sort of see what
happens
if one could always just say let me let
me check my science
oh i know you know the result of
everything is going to be 42. i don't
need to
live my life and do what i do it's just
we already know the answer
it's actually good news in a sense that
there is this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
that doesn't allow you to just sort of
jump through time
and say this is the answer so to speak
um and that's so that's a good thing
the bad thing is it doesn't allow you to
jump through time and know what the
answer is
you